[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
road to 2000 as always my name is caleb
denby and i will be your driver on this
journey
um today's a pretty exciting day i think
it's our first day back online since the
mass mandate's been lifted
so you can see my entire face today
hopefully that makes a difference for
you
um what i wanted to talk about today is
the most exciting thing going on in
chess right now and that is the race for
the candidates 2022 that's uh entering
its final stages here so of course the
final qualification spots are determined
by the ongoing fide grand prix
tournament so what is the fide grand
prix
well it's a really complicated format of
three different tournaments where
everybody involved plays in two of the
three tournaments and you get points
based on how you place within the
tournaments so
we are on the third and final tournament
in the grand prix so we will know by the
end of this tournament who is getting
those last two qualification spots
um now if you follow
chess politics and world politics you
might have heard that sergey karjakin
has also lost his candidate's spot i
believe that is going to the next
highest person on the active rating list
so that might go to ding laren but he
might need to play some more chess in
order to actually qualify for it i think
he's inactive so that's up in the air
but what we're focusing on are these
grand prix spots uh getting there the
the way it was designed
so what's going on in the grand prix so
far um one man richard rapport has a
very excellent shot of qualifying he
played in the first two tournaments so
he's actually done he's banked all his
points he's done and now he just has to
wait and see if anybody can beat him
of course the top two
the top two finishers in the grand prix
are going to qualify so richard looking
pretty safe there's only one or two
scenarios where he doesn't qualify or i
think lavonne loses in the final to one
of three different people and then it
depends on tie breaks it's a complicated
mess
the the real story is in the group stage
right now between levon aronian and
nakaru nakamura these are number two and
three behind richard and they are
actually in the same group for this last
tournament in the grand prix hopefully
some of that made sense there was a lot
of complicated chess tournament formats
but the long and short of it is levon
aronian and okay nakamura both have
excellent chances to qualify if they do
well in this tournament but they have to
get through each other first only one
person qualifies from the group stage
and the person who doesn't make it out
of the group stage probably not going to
qualify
so today was the first round and we got
to see the big matchup right away lavon
versus ikaru so of course that is the
game that i'm going to start with this
might already have been the game that
decides who makes it to the candidates
between these two players
so levon had the white pieces and if you
followed the first tournament you'll
notice that lavon and akaru met in the
finals once before and ikaru managed to
win on tiebreaks so lavon looking for
some revenge here plays the move d4 we
get d5 from makaru c4
d takes c4
and we are officially in the queen's
gambit accepted
now a very normal move here is to play
knight to f3 that's going to keep things
pretty simple it's going to defend the
e5 square
prevent black from breaking in the
center with e5 and just work on
developing the pieces
but levon plays the more aggressive move
e4
now after e4 there's a lot of things
that black can do uh the quote unquote
normal way to equalize is actually this
move e5 that's why a lot of players
myself included prefer to go knight f3
because after e4 e5 is thought to to
equalize for black
uh however the karu chooses very much a
sideline in the form of pawn to b5
so have you guys ever seen this one
before
maybe not this exact position but you've
seen this idea right black tries to hold
onto the pawn with b5
so it turns out levonaronian had seen
this idea before because this was
actually tried against him in stage one
of the grand prix this is what lenie
dominguez played against lavonne so
hikaru perhaps watched that game thought
lenie had some good ideas in this line
and chose to repeat it against levon now
we'll see how that strategy worked out
for him because that can be a little bit
double-edged uh sometimes you're able to
surprise
uh your opponent when you go into a line
that you know that they play or
sometimes they have a second idea that
you're not ready for so let's see what
happens here so we get a4
the very normal response to b5 you want
to weaken the c4 pawn you want to be
able to capture on c4 and so you want to
remove this defender to do that
now we get the move c6
a take b5
just a generally useful move for white
we open our rook on the a file black's
work remains closed in the a file so
there's not really a reason to not do
this
uh c takes b5 and then knight c3 so out
of curiosity does anybody know what
would happen if white's pawn were on e3
here this is one of the first chest
straps i learned i think yeah
yeah queen to f3 it's exactly right you
would have queen f3 and if the pawn were
on e3
you would be attacking this rook the
rook is actually trapped and there's no
way to defend the rook so black has to
lose a piece with like knight knight c6
or something
um with the pawn on e4 that's not going
to work out because the diagonal is shut
so
just one more reason why black is able
to go for this b5 move in this
particular line
um so what does lavon do well he just
develops his pieces with knight to c3
and then the weirdness sort of continues
with this move queen to b6 and we are
very much off the beaten path now this
has been played uh i think well now nine
times in the lead chess database only
eight times in the lead chess database
but they haven't added this last game
yet
um and in half the games white plays
this move b3 and half the games white
plays knight d5 levon stuck with what he
did against lenier dominguez just played
knight to d5 and now we're sort of
leaving the realm of normal chess
openings where both sides are developing
pieces and controlling the center and
more just entering the the territory of
computer preparation you know both these
players had seen this position before
and they're really just going to start
to get crazy with it so
why play knight to d5 uh well it gains a
tempo on the queen and after the queen
goes back to b7
white is going to say you haven't
developed any pieces and that means i
can play bishop f4 and you have no good
way to respond to the threat of knight
to c7
and this turns out to be true
black has no good way to respond to
knight to c7 so instead black allows
knight c7 and goes on the offensive so
stick with me here we're going to play
pawn e5 which is a sacrifice
we don't really want to take with the
pawn because we lose the threat of
knight to c7 so bishop takes
and now rather than defend against this
you know sort of desperately trying like
knight a6 which just loses to rook a6
and there's really no other legal way to
defend it uh instead of all that black
is just going to develop with knight to
d7
and the point being made here is that
after you play knight to c7 and knight
to a8 black is going to be striking back
in the center and maybe your your knight
on a8 is stuck
so just to show you what that looks like
if we tried this immediately
takes oh actually sorry
oh maybe i shouldn't have shown you what
this looks like it's always so
complicated
um all right let's cheat cheating's
great yeah king to d8 and if you take on
a8 what happens uh bishop b4 check is
immediately the problem
when this is checkmate
okay
so that's one to look out for
um
so there you go that's what happens if
you do it immediately now now we know so
lavon steps back with bishop f4 instead
um black now develops but knight g to f6
and now thanks to our bishop covering
the square we are actually allowed to
play the move knight to c7
so lavon does
captures on a8
hikaru rather than playing bishop b4
check first uh just starts with queen
takes e4
we get knight to e2
then hikaru does have to recapture the
piece
and
uh due to the forcing nature of those
last uh few moves this is really the
first option hey levi come on in
enjoy join the class uh you didn't miss
much we're just talking about uh
uh the grand prix that's going on right
now the professional tournament the
grand prix and the fight for the last
candidates qualification spots
um okay so queen takes a8 and this is
really the first opportunity for either
side to deviate in the game against leni
dominguez lavon played this move f3 and
it turned out to be a pretty crazy game
there was a lot of back and forth
lavon was winning and then he wasn't and
he was winning and then he wasn't and
then he ended up winning the game
anyways
uh but here levon decided to surprise a
cargo first with queen to d2
which is not what was played against
lennier just to show you how the game
against lenie went white played f3
what's the point of f3 well you're
probably not going to have enough time
to castle so it gives your king the f2
square it also helps defend against
knight e4 knight g4 ideas
and
you'll see in the game that after knight
to d5
white slowly but surely starts to
untangle goes knight g3 king f2 bishop
e2 rookie one and he just barely gets
the pieces in and is able to run away
with the king
and then here actually lanier had
already done enough wrong that this is
just entirely losing
why isn't entirely losing well
black's king is actually the more unsafe
one in the position being stuck in the
center and of course
uh materially white has an extra uh rook
for a piece here up in exchange and is
able to just very concretely open a
bunch of files like b3 and files are
just going to get ripped open here
and the tactics work out in lavon's
favor and then eventually you know other
things happen and the evaluation changes
a bunch of times
but opening went well for lavon
so i'm not sure where uh hikaru was
hoping to improve on lanier dominguez's
line but we'll never know because levon
chooses queen to d2 instead doesn't play
this move f3 chooses queen to d2
so you're not going to surprise akaru
with the first deviation he knew what he
was doing goes knight d5 we get knight
to c3 now so a very different line than
f3 so far
rather than going this way with the
pieces and trying to hurriedly run the
king over
you see lavon just taking a more normal
approach to developing just going to
bring this bishop out to e2 most likely
and just try to castle king's side
bishop b4 is how hikaru keeps up the
pressure
looking to bear down on the e-file and
keep pressure up over here
peace trades are obviously going to be
good for white because white's behind in
development and is up in material
we do get bishop e2 and now after rook
to e8 lavon deviates again with bishop
g3 if you ask the computer here which
i'm gonna flip it on uh it likes king to
f1 the best maybe this is what hikaru
had in his preparation but bishop g3
actually isn't much worse at all white
does have a few options along the road
here so bishop g3 and i think this was
the first moment where hikaru started to
spend some time
so whenever you're playing a crazy
opening like this um it's never good
when you're the first one to start start
spending time uh so aronian does win the
opening battle here
uh what does the car play though he
starts with knight seven to f6 which
makes a lot of sense you know you're
trying to play something like knight e4
someday and take advantage of the pin
attack all of the white pieces basically
um but lavonne was not perturbed he just
castled king's side and allowed knight
e4 and stepped the queen out of the way
with uh queen to c2
okay then
uh what to do with black well akaru
thinks for i think close to 20 no just
just eight minutes taking about eight
minutes every turn
and plays bishop f5
so now i think levon ironian still in
preparation somehow immediately plays
bishop to h4 check
and in the post-game interview i think
this is where hikaru said he spent a lot
of his time
so let's see if we can
digest some of this position this is
where i'm going to stop sort of flying
through all the moves and we're going to
start start trying to engage with it a
little bit more so you're kara nakamura
you're out of the opening here uh
out of your opening prep
so what can you do to uh to stay in this
game
let's just stop and take stock a little
bit first of all you're in check
you have threats against the knight on
c3 you have all your pieces sort of well
placed in the center of the board but
your king is is a little bit weak so
whatever you do you want it to be very
very active and
reasonably forcing otherwise white is
slowly but surely going to try to
untangle
so how do you want to deal with bishop
h4 check let's come up with some ideas
f6
yep so f6 is uh probably the most
natural idea right you just block the
check and you give the turn back to
white
g5 yeah yeah g5 uh as the in-person
audience and actually alex in the chat
says
um
yeah i think alex is nearby he asks uh
g5 which the advantage of this move it
looks a little bit less
safe
but it does have the advantage of
gaining a tempo on the bishop
and you can make an argument for playing
something like king to c8 but let's
stick with with these two options so
these are by far the most natural two
options right so
which one do you want to start with if
you were playing in the game which of
these options would you kind of
calculate first
g5
okay why g5
i
would tend to look the most forcing one
yeah
so
that's a good argument uh you want to
calculate g5 first and think about g5
first because it's the most forcing move
now does anybody disagree
no dissenters
okay
so this is where
i am actually going to to disagree so
whenever you are solving like a tactics
puzzle for example right they always
tell you look at the forcing moves first
because that's oftentimes
um you know like how you went in a
tactics puzzle
uh but i think that this advice isn't
always what you should do
in your over-the-board games so yes if
there is a simple win then it's useful
to look at the forcing moves first and
see if there's a simple win
however it doesn't take long looking at
g5 to understand that it's not going to
be simple at all right this position is
is just
not even remotely simple there are a lot
of different moves you can calculate and
we'll get into some of those momentarily
but it's going to take you a long time
to decide if g5 is is playable because
it's it's very risky right this pawn is
on a square where it's attacked um you
have to calculate bishop g5 uh you have
to calculate what's what's happening
there because if if knight g5 then queen
f5 obviously so
there's a lot to calculate which e5 is
what i'm saying whereas if you start
with the move f6 this is the
quote-unquote simpler looking move right
you want to start with the normal move
in a lot of instances
and now you don't want to spend like all
of your time on f6 like just thinking
thinking thinking on about f6 but you at
least want to check this move you want
to say okay
is my position okay if i just play f6
and what that's going to do for you is
that's going to let you calculate g5
with a lot more confidence because you
can say okay
i've been thinking about this move g5
for a long time now um i'm not really
coming to any conclusions uh i guess i
should just you know rely on this f6
move that i've already thought about
it's sort of like a
a safety net that you can you know
create for yourself by by thinking about
the normal moves first
now uh again you do want to check the
forcing moves like you want to check
knight c3 other knight c3 bishop c3 okay
well those are illegal here but you want
to check those those kinds of ideas
um
very very quickly but i wouldn't suggest
doing like a deep dive into like
calculating out g5 uh
before you know you even really consider
f6 so that that's the point i wanted to
make here it is really useful to to look
at the normal move at least for a little
bit
until you convince yourself whether you
know okay f6 definitely isn't okay i
can't play this i have to find something
else or you know okay f6 looks like it
might be okay let's see if i'm winning
with g5
um however what hikaru did is spend a
lot of time about 20 minutes and then
play f6 so in the post game interview he
said he spent all that time calculating
g5 so i guess let's look at it what's
going on after g5 what's going on here
so i might have hinted at the main
variation right
so what ideas are there for for whites
with the bishop
yeah takes on g5 is is going to be
really important
right so if we take and take then queen
f5
and
the tactics sort of continue here like
maybe knight c3 is important
but this note in g5 kind of hangs with
czech
yeah so bishop takes f6 is maybe gonna
be uh important as well so
uh i guess let's agree on this this one
does this look good for black is black
able to do this
see if we can get to to some kind of
conclusion
it's actually not so easy to tell
yeah so you definitely still have to be
careful here with white for example if
knight to c3
what should white do
so i think this one actually doesn't
work i think black can block with bishop
b7
and then you have too many too many
pieces hanging
um
maybe you're still okay after something
like queen to d2 but it it looks very
very suspicious
maybe you are still okay here but i
think that the simpler way to go is to
just take the pawn
and now um
let's see the material count white is
still up in exchange if you take on c3
now i do take with check and you don't
have bishop e7 and if you retreat
if nothing else you know i can take b5 i
can do any number of things bishop f3
if i want to keep it simple and white's
just going to be up in exchange so
knight takes g5 no good
so what else is there after bishop g5
well as brian mentioned maybe the move
f6 so
let's think about that now what are we
doing after f6
okay uh d5 you said yeah
yeah so
that's definitely something you have to
calculate let's
so i guess we can start with that i also
want to ask
what happens if white does the simple
thing and retreats the bishop what is
actually black's threat this is always a
useful question to ask like if white
just wastes a tempo and saves a piece
what is what is black actually
threatening
or was it all a lie was there no threat
in the first place
sometimes that's that's also true
uh
what what on c3
knight e takes
or d takes
d takes
okay and then white takes
one of the other back pointing at it
yeah okay other knight takes and maybe
queen f5
uh with the knight or the rook
always options
so that's check and then okay king h1
and where do we kind of stand at the end
of this line
uh who is uh
black is down
yeah so uh white black woodwind material
in that line here i'll go and put it on
the board but just to kind of show you
that's
that's how you do the complete
calculating process you say okay i'm
thinking about this move let's say takes
takes now this looks like the most
forcing uh otherwise you know if if you
just do something like this
uh maybe
white's gonna start fighting back
something like
bishop f3 could actually cause you some
problems
um so this is more forcing and so you
think okay queen f5 knight e2 king h1
and sort of what's going on here then
you sort of pause and say okay well i
could take d4 but i can't actually
because you know f6 hangs with check and
so does my knight
and so it seems like black kind of runs
out of threats here right and we haven't
actually won any big material we just
won a pawn on c3
um so knight d takes maybe not the the
best way to go for black i think black
can do better
so you found the the critical pattern
which is that uh this bishop on e2 is
going to end up attacked if we take on
c3 with the knight right
but uh the move order wasn't quite right
yeah i think knight e takes is the
simplest bishop takes might also be very
good but knight e takes is definitely
the most forcing this is the one that i
would you know kind of find first in a
game so
knight e takes and of course you're not
able to recapture this because of the
threat on the queen
and so after queen d f5 you can take e2
and then black actually has a turn here
this uh pawn is defended once we can
defend it again
maybe with
queen to c6 maybe i'm worried about uh
maybe i'm worried about my a7 pawn i
don't think so so i'll play queen to c6
let's say you get greedy and take
i'll take on d4
and now black is controlling sort of all
all the squares all the important
squares at least i think so i don't
think i've blundered anything here
um and what is the material count well
we have two knights for a rook so black
is no longer so unhappy about uh about
the material and
we have a lot of pieces around our king
to help defend
um
so knight e takes i think is what i
would find first bishop takes might
might also be very good uh let's go
ahead and cheat let's see how we did
calculating yeah bishop takes very
strong this line also very good
also very good
and here it actually likes a5 above all
the other moves just to keep this rook
out of play which i guess makes makes
some sense
um
you do lose this pawn
but it does not matter because your
queen and rook can defend against the
lone queen and the other rooks are shut
out
so there you go we're professional
calculators look at us we did it
so what's the deal uh what's the deal
then white cannot play the simple move
bishop h4 that's what we just determined
so in a game that's sort of what you
want to be thinking about maybe first
thinking okay well
um
is this even like worth continuing like
what if white just ignores me am i am i
doing something and the answer is yes
so now we have a really good
understanding of what black's threats
are we're threatening to go knight e to
c3 we're threatening to go bishop c3
followed by 90 to c3
um
and we're also attacking the bishop on
g5 so we understand what black is
threatening now so now that we know that
uh now it's a little bit easier to find
some options for white so how can white
try and deal with these these threats
what does white gonna attempt to do
there's a question in the chat
which i'll briefly show so just to show
this is also a way to continue for black
is defending with knight g3 knight ge3
is also a potential threat
um it's also very very strong
it's also very very strong it's almost
equivalent to 90 to c3 first but black
is winning in both lines
right so
uh one of
the threats is to take on g5
so bishop takes f6 has been suggested
which is just sort of tossing the bishop
and in exchange we get a tempo to do
something with our knight right so let's
say bishop takes f6 um black has two
options i guess
this one is
i think pretty clearly no good because
of queen f5
as i'm saying that uh maybe
the bishop c3 is still going to be
somewhat annoying
i kind of doubt it i kind of doubt that
it's so annoying i think bishop c3 we
can just take if knight c3 by the way
that leaves the snake behind at the end
so bishop c3 bc3 if you end up taking
here yes you do get two knights for the
rook but the difference now is that my
rooks are actually
kind of invading and that's going to
cause you some some headaches here for
sure especially with your queen queen on
a8
um
so
uh that leaves this other option and the
question is is this one
is this one good enough for black
what do we think
so it looks like it might be right
it looks complicated for sure but um it
looks like white doesn't really have a
good way to to continue here
um there's not really like a stellar
defensive move that's going to solve
everything and by the way you have
already sacrificed your piece back
maybe you can play something like bishop
to f3 and that's going to keep the game
going
because
this pin sort of counteracts this
discovery in some really really strange
strange looking way um but i'm not so
sure that you've actually achieved much
for example i just play like queen to b8
right i just unpin
seems like you're gonna have a lot of
the same problems and black has already
regained regained a piece um again it's
gonna have in this case a bishop and a
knight in exchange for a rook
so
uh nate you know d to f6 like i'm not
100 confident that that black is like
crushing here
but
it looks like a defensive move isn't
really enough so maybe white has to try
an active move so what kind of active
ideas
would white be able to consider in a
position like this
okay so f3 in a sense it's kind of
active but it is also like sort of
asking for um
for these ideas that that black already
wants to play right
i'm not so sure if i want to go there
immediately or if i want to take and
then go knight g3
um or if take if you're taking here
um then there's takes on d4 takes on e4
i think you might actually get checked
muted there
um just to show
check
take
and this is awkward
um maybe you have like bishop f3 again
which is this move is always just so
crazy but
um looks pretty good for black i think
uh no matter what i mean knight g4 stuff
even
um so f3 not not quite not quite
yeah so knight takes b5 this move sort
of comes out of nowhere right like uh
it's definitely not first on your list
but when you sit at the position a
little bit and you think about what you
can do to to get active and it takes b5
definitely is going to come to mind
eventually now why this move well
number one it removes the knight from
these threats of capture
number two
you'll notice that in all these lines
where knight g3 is happening you don't
really exactly have a good move with the
queen right your queen is sort of just
stuck back here and so with knight to b5
you actually introduce this idea of
queen take c4 as well and once you start
seeing this idea you might start to get
some hope
for white's position because up until
this point it has looked pretty rough
for for white but now that you see queen
take c4 like
let's say for example knight g3 happens
here
you take on c4 and yeah black gets this
with check you move out of the way but
all of a sudden it's it's black who has
some some problems to solve this bishop
is hanging and let's not forget that
queen c7 is is a checkmating threat
so we can see how
this idea might become very very useful
now the question is is it useful enough
here because
uh what what on earth is going on if we
count the pieces black i think has three
pieces in exchange for a rook right now
maybe they can give one back somehow
maybe they can can survive this
but now that we've seen this idea of
knight to b5 i find that it's useful
sometimes once you've been spending some
time on a line to just go back to the
beginning and sort of
uh recap from here so after f6
uh
with our our new uh bucket of ideas
considering moves like bishop f3 it
removes like knight b5
you know maybe there's something else we
should consider before bishop f6
so it's not a trick question what what
new idea were we just looking at
yeah knight to b5
and uh i don't think it's too hard to
understand why
this is a more active attempt than
bishop f6 so with bishop f6 you spend a
full move to get your bishop captured
versus if you play knight to b5
and black captures your bishop now black
has spent the move to capture your
bishop instead of you spending the the
move on on capturing this pawn
uh so these types of like desperado
moves look kind of tempting at first
when you are thinking that your piece is
just doomed but sometimes especially in
a position like this the extra tempo is
worth more than the the pawn that you
would capture
so by not playing bishop takes f6 and
making your opponent play something
takes g5 you in a sense are kind of
gaining a tempo with uh with this move
so knight to b5
it turns out that black is is actually a
little bit short on on ideas here so
uh there are i think really
uh
two main ideas for for black to consider
here and we can we can go through both
of them so
at least i only have two ideas maybe you
guys have more what do you think for
black in this position
okay the chat's first idea is one that i
did not consider so
off to a good start
i guess that is an interesting idea
though
okay the chat came up with knight g3
which again i i agree is going to be an
important idea
it's um
threatens to win a piece
because we gain a tempo on the queen and
we attack e2
so we will definitely have to keep an id
uh and i on on knight to g3
and then what else could black try just
to win the game
and this is complicated stuff so
any ideas
i heard an intake of breath
i mean i'm just afraid
uh
i'm afraid
yeah right so
yeah okay so you there are there are
defensive moves like rookie seven the
chat also suggested this idea which is a
very defensive move
um but yeah what i was looking for is
just knight g3 is an attacking idea f
takes g5 also just just captures a piece
and it turns out that both of these
moves just aren't aren't going to be
very good before we look at the
defensive ideas so so knight g3 for
example
the queen's attacked so we do have to do
something
i'm thinking we can just take on
take on c4
it's true that you do get to take this
piece with check
but as you're pointing out this threat
of rick takes a seven turns out it's
gonna be really really uh important and
really difficult for black to stop so i
think
that white is just close to winning here
uh
again
although
now that i'm looking at it and i
am unassisted by computers it again
looks looks incredibly complicated to
just try to understand um from a human's
perspective like now i'm thinking maybe
your mover takes a set or rookie seven
might be worth trying
um but i think at the end of the day
we're gonna go
knight day seven and we're gonna be
trying to come into c6
and if you take
i take back and if you take i can take
on d5 and again you're running into this
issue where uh
where your pieces are just sort of
scattered and your king is wide open
um so knight g3 i don't think it's going
to be good enough we can ask the
the computer to make sure i'm not lying
to you guys
okay it turns out queen takes c4 white
is slightly better um but bishop takes
f6 is the way to go first and then queen
takes c4
and this makes a lot of sense it just
makes these threats a little bit more
more severe
um and the point now is that this is
hanging this is hanging and if you do
try this move knight to d5 then rook to
a7 is is going to be crushing
so knight g3 no good because we can
distract the the knight with bishop f6
in that case and if you do go f takes g5
then yes this mover takes a7 is is going
to be quite good
um if you get hit with queen c6 we just
take on c4
and
uh it's true that black has gotten uh
gotten the piece uh but in return we
have one two three pawns and a rook for
for two pieces so white is is just gonna
be quite a bit better here and i think
something similar happens after
um
knight to d6
where we should be able to
save enough material here
to just be uh
sort of statically better with with
white you know we can we can save some
stuff yeah you go queen a4
if black tries to capture the piece now
we can take
if take apparently queen a5 check is
strong so rook takes e2
and then we take on f5
and the pieces start to come off we
actually have to go f3 here rook g2
queen b7
and then we get in with queen a7 and
it's like plus one all right white's
white's doing great
so it turns out knight to d6 i think is
actually the best idea which uh somehow
i missed this when i was doing some prep
but yeah knight to d6
and uh
white is is somehow ending up on the
plus side of things
so if you're normal people like you or
me uh we spend like 25 minutes and then
eventually ask the computer to help
guide us along
and then we realize that g5 is no good
if you're a car nakamura you spend 20
minutes and you're like yeah okay yeah
i've calculated enough and you go f6
so
uh
hopefully that gave you guys some
insight into how calculating in these
super complicated positions can can work
right you uh just sort of break them
down into a few different ideas and you
try to see how those ideas can work with
each other and you see how they work in
different lines
and that's how you can start to arrive
at at some kind of answer in these
positions
so once again just to recap how we got
there we saw g5 we said okay so if takes
uh starting with this knight g5 is no
good so we're gonna think about f6
from there in order to get a good
feeling for what black's ideas were we
said okay well what happens if white
just retreats the bishop then once we
understood that you know knight g3
taking on c3
these are black's ideas we started to
come up with this nice active idea of
knight to b5 to help fight back and help
stop some of these ideas that that black
has so that's how it sort of all flows
together in these these complicated
calculations you go from one step to the
next eventually arrive it as some kind
of an answer
now is your answer always correct no but
hopefully that gives you some kind of a
road map for uh for taking these kinds
of positions on
um okay instead we get pawn to f6 and
now levon aronian
i think very quickly again plays this
move bishop to f3
so because uh black has not gone crazy
with the king side pawns we don't have
quite as much freedom to go crazy over
here on the queen side because we just
have less pressure around the king with
uh this sort of diagonal attack and
intact and these pawns intact
so levon chooses the defensive idea of
bishop f3 instead
um so what does this do well we're
taking a look at what black's ideas were
knight g3 and knight c3 both of these
help rely on the idea of the bishop on
e2 being hanging so we put the bishop on
f3 instead and make it a little bit more
awkward for black to move these knights
um
hikaru finds the move bishop takes c3
lavon of course captures back
and now he gets uh pawn to g5
and surprisingly here there are a few
moves for
whites the one that levon plays i think
is the most human
so of course is bishop is bishop g3
possible is the first question
yeah i agree so bishop g3 is no good
because again black does still have this
idea of knight takes g3
when you can't recapture because the
queen is attacked so it just looks good
for black
so if we can't do bishop g3 how are we
going to solve our problems here how do
we ever escape
and in this instance i think the chat is
one step ahead of me
yeah so bishop b4 is a good try but i
think uh black does keep the tempo here
black keeps the tempo with bishop takes
i guess
yeah rook fe1 is is the human tray um
and this is what levon plays in the game
um and this is the first moment when he
really spent a lot of time so i think
maybe finally he's playing by his own
brain
as they say so
why rook after e1 well one of the
problems with knight g3 was the detector
rook as well and so we would probably
rather you know number one we just want
to get this rook in the game number two
help step out of some of some of this
idea
number three it also makes a counter
threat to g takes h4 right we're
threatening to take back on e for
regaining the piece
the computer says
um
you know pieces don't matter you're all
idiots play queen b2 go take on b5 or
something and play the game but rook fe1
makes sense
um
hikaru comes up with this move knight to
f4
so
what's the idea of knight f4 well number
one it adds a defender to e4 so this
knight is no longer hanging
and since this net is no longer hanging
it renews the threat
against this bishop on h4
so
what's the big idea now for
levonaronian
see if you can find the winning move
and this one i mean i'm not even going
to advise you try to calculate all the
way to the ends
but with the ideas that we've looked at
so far maybe it's not going to be quite
as shocking as
as it might have been otherwise
it's not bishop g5
so i did not consider bishop g5 um
i think maybe here uh so you're hoping
for like knight takes when you know all
the things are happening but i think
black instead would just play pawn takes
and uh
now again we we've kept this knight
defended i'm not sure what the next move
here would would be for for white
so someone in the chat mentioned bishop
g3 again i think this still
doesn't quite actually maybe bishop g3
is fine
okay i'm gonna put a hold on bishop g3
i'll have to think about that one
um i was gonna say it doesn't work
because i think knight g3 is still good
but
maybe white is is actually close to
winning there after
just
rookie 8
queen f5 and bishop a8 ideas i don't
know i'll have to think about it
with the the boldest suggestion of the
knight says g4 but i think it's
it's a little too much it's a little too
much
there's like checks there's like there's
everything just too scary too scary
okay so you're thinking rook a7 with the
idea of diverting the queen from the
knight right
um so this would be a really good idea
if
uh we weren't back rank mated but i
think we are actually back rank baited
here
so
yeah if not for queen a1 at the end i
think this would make a lot of sense
um
because even at the end of the line you
know we're sort of on the night so this
move is no good but
we do actually get checkmated
unfortunately
yeah a lot of my ideas are pretty good
except for
yeah so in this case once again now is
the correct moment to to play the move
queen a2 and the point is we just come
in and capture over here on the queen
um and
outside of you know really deep
calculation which is obviously involved
although lavon spent all of three
minutes on this move
um
you can arrive at this kind of move by
by sort of understanding that you have a
little bit of leeway to work with here
right you
are actually still up in exchange for a
pawn in the position
so
black winning one of your pieces is
actually not the end of the world then
if black wins one of your pieces you
have two pieces for a rook
and if uh you end up in that imbalance
and you're able to like invade and
capture all your opponent's pawns
it might end up being actually quite
good for you
so let's think about what's going on
here
um if
uh black were in fact to play this move
uh g takes h4
let's let's see what's going on
so
uh i think it is actually a little bit
simple i'm not gonna ask you guys to
calculate this one out i think we can
just go queen a7 here
and the point now
is that
this knights is actually
uh a little bit stuck is this the point
i think we might need to give a check
first
might need to give a check first
all right
it's too late in the lecture we're gonna
ask it's queen a5 check yeah queen a5
check and then after king c8 we just we
take over here
and we're attacking this guy we're
attacking this guy we're attacking all
the guys
of course if you step up
now i think we can take on a7
um nope that doesn't work okay we still
take on b5
and after
this one now we can take here
and go queen c7 and we just we're mating
along along the seventh rank okay
so complicated stuff complicated stuff
um but yeah queen takes b5 here is is
pretty sensible and if you try to save
all the pieces you can go check
and take and you are pinned and attacked
and losing losing the chess game so so
sad
so queen to a2 is sort of the
devastating idea
which is why uh hikaru came up with the
move queen to b7 to defend the b pawn
because the the key lines sort of
revolve around taking on on b5 here
um and now levon does just play this
move queen takes a seven
um in the post game interview hagar was
actually very critical and was
suggesting like you know after queen a5
check he would just resign or something
um
which these lines still remain a little
bit complicated what lavon did was
enough to get into a much better end
game which should just be winning um
hikaru felt that you know this move gave
him more drawing chances in this kind of
end game but uh
it was enough for levanto to go on to
win
so takes takes was played
and now
uh
if you do want to take here
um i think you no longer
lose by force
now you do lose by force to check when i
can take this guy and take this guy
okay so that's why rookie six was played
to step out of this idea
and now
levon simply simplifies
simply simplifies and hikaru is able to
use these past pawns to win a piece back
like so
and then lavon is able to just win this
end game with these these two extra
pawns thanks to all the weaknesses on
the black king's site to show you what
that looks like here
he pushes b6 and d5
they dance around for a long time caru
is able to pick up the queen side pawns
but in return they end up in this
position
where after bringing the rook to
a1 just want to highlight this really
quickly the rook is a long range piece
and in these end games you very very
often want to be checking from very very
far away you want to be using your rook
from far away that way it's not going to
get hassled by the king or the knight
and has a lot more more freedom of
movement
um
so in the game he goes rook d 1 rook d2
trying to do a little zugzwang
then
moves the king up eventually plays f5
and is able to invade with the king
and eventually sacrifice to
uh get this winning position after king
h7
king f4
when king h6 is the way to win
um just to show you i think there were
other easier ways to win well not easier
but other ways to win as well
i think he's also winning after f6 i
think he's also winning after
most most moves here i think it's hard
to not be winning in this position
is f6 winning f6 is not winning f6 is
winning f6 might be winning but why
bother just uh transposing to the
winning end game
um i think f6
f6 at some moment was winning yeah f6
here was winning if you don't want to go
uh go crazy with with this other kind of
stuff
um because yeah because now black isn't
defending this pawn
so that was the crazy crazy game between
lavon aronian and
today
um absolutely wild stuff hopefully you
learned a little bit
about calculating and how you can kind
of try to organize your thoughts uh from
this game that was sort of my goal with
it going in
with the last few minutes i want to
actually show you guys a position
between richard rapport and dmitry and
draken from the previous leg uh unless
you guys have questions for me because
this was a very complicated game the the
focus i want you guys to take away from
it is that idea of how to calculate in
such complicated positions but uh but
any questions on the game on chess on
anything at all
anything
yeah justin
was a um end game several moves back it
was very much not clear
yeah no i mean it it's not clear which
is why hikaru thought levon shouldn't
have gone for it um
but it's just i just know that the sun
game is winning because i've looked at
it i wouldn't know off the top of my
head that this was winning either to be
honest with you
um
but uh just to give you sort of a
general rule of thumb for these kind of
things
when you have a rook against two minor
pieces the two minor pieces are
generally a lot better in the middle
game when they can work with other
pieces and coordinate once you get to
the end game
the advantage of having two pieces it
still is better than a rook in most
instances
but it's often much less important
and so the number of pawns does become
sort of more important than having two
pieces for the rook
um
and in this case having two pawns in the
rook for the two pieces along with the
fact that all these pawns on the king
side are weak
is enough for for lavon to to be winning
that's that's a great question because i
agree that's not obvious at all this is
winning
any other questions
okay well in that case we do have four
minutes left and i just want to show you
uh what kind of a monster richard
rapport is so they played this boring
game oh my god it's so boring
so boring nobody wants to see this
nobody wants to see this and then all of
a sudden we get to this position
and richard rapport is making threats
against e6
uh and draken plays knight e4 to try to
stop those and rapport plays this sort
of annoying move f3
and it turns out this move is very very
threatening um if black were to just
retreat the knight
white is planning to go rook e1 and it
is illegal for you to defend this pawn
another time you can try it's it's
illegal i guess you could play rookie
four that's the only way
um and so because of that black is close
to losing if if you play something like
net f6 so instead of retreating the
knight uh and draken comes up with this
repetition idea rip to c3 rook to d4
rook to c3 to c4
uh and then because richard poor is just
a calculating demon and monster he plays
queen to e5 here
which looks really good looks really
good you're threatening to take on e6 um
but it does allow knight to d2
uh which attacks your rook and attacks
this pawn on f3 and if you move your
rick away then you lose a queen if you
move your rook up then you get checked
and you're actually in quite a lot of
trouble here quite a lot of trouble
so
after knight to d2 report calculated f5
and then uh the lines here just get
absolutely insane uh queen to b6 check
was i think the easiest way to draw for
black and after king h1 knight to f1 uh
white has to find f takes e6 then black
has to find king to g8 and then white
has to go for this absolutely absurd
repetition
where we can check with the queen
and the king can never take on e6
because we win the queen
so rapport i guess had this repetition
in his back pocket he calculates all of
this he says yeah i'm totally fine here
uh and draken tries this move knight
takes f1
we get f takes e6 anyways
and then somewhat shockingly king to g8
no longer good enough to draw uh king f8
obviously not good enough to draw
because
uh you know obviously whatever i think
queen f5 point f7 is is why
um kingdom e8 played in the game also
not good enough to draw he had to find
this move king to e7 which on the
surface looks like the worst of all the
options hanging this pawn with check
this is the only way to draw but the
idea being the king needs to be able to
go to d6 so that it can run to the kings
to the queen side and be safe
instead after king to e8 rapport finds
queen to g7 then after queen b6 we take
on f1
and then rapport somehow calculated that
he can keep the king the queen boxed out
with the king
and uh sort of just chase after this
rook
when despite being completely surrounded
there are no good checks for black the
king is like on in the eye of the storm
it's just absolutely insane
um
so instead and draken does the only
thing he really can do which is rook to
e1 check which i say the only thing you
really can do queen to c7 would have
been a lot more testing it has to find a
very complicated line but he goes rick
to e1 check
takes check
and check
and i think at some point in draken must
have thought that this was good enough
for a draw that there was no way to
escape the perpetual check
but uh richard report has that's
just an incredible way to escape the
perpetual check thanks to believe it or
not this bishop on on h3
so how do you get out of this kind of
perpetual check where black is chasing
around with a queen while either you
need to be able to get your king up the
board somehow towards your other pieces
or you need to be able to bring your
other pieces back home so in this case
poor has a nice king maneuver to
actually force black to check
in such a way that he can block with the
queen and then go on to escape the
checks so it goes king c1
check king b1
check
king c1 okay they repeat once now king
to b2
queen to d2 is played
uh king to a1 queen to c1
and then out after king to a2 it seems
like black should still be able to draw
uh because we can check from c4 and then
we don't have to check from this way and
allow the queen to block on b2 right so
it seems like maybe black gets away with
it maybe black can draw thanks to queen
to c4 but actually this whole maneuver
was designed to draw the queen out to c4
because now after king to b2 you no
longer have queen to d2 check you have
to play queen to e2 check
and now
after sorry so you saw the funny last
move but after queen to d1 king to a2
we've drawn the queen to d1 rather than
c1 which means you have to check from
the second rank which means we can block
with the queen and then go on to to
escape with the queen or with the king
so this is why miraculously
white is only winning here because the
f1 square is defended if the f1 square
were not defended then after queen to f1
king to a2 queen to c4 check we do
actually have perpetual check
um so
and draken in the game actually realized
this and played queen f1 check anyways
uh after which richard rapport captured
the queen and and won the game in style
uh all but securing his spot in the
candidates this year
um
so i just wanted to show you guys that
that absolutely insane game that richard
rapport played i don't know how many
people on planet earth would play queen
e5 here instead of taking that
repetition
i'm starting to think there might only
be one um which is really saying
something
um just an absolute demon
okay so that's all i have for you guys
tonight um hopefully you all can stick
around we have a brand new grand master
in residence uh robert gungoski is back
and this is his first lecture tonight i
would recommend you guys all stick
around check it out um as always my name
is caleb denby and i want to thank you
very much for joining me on the road
2000 tonight as always i will see you
guys next time
[Music]
you